hi Joseph Robinette Biden Jr do solemnly
swear think about the challenge that
Biden faces
he's an adversarial relationships from
the start
December we kept asking for the plan and
there wasn't a plan even in that moment
of joy of renewal people were extremely
conscious of
The Inheritance we had
[Music]
we were playing catch-up from the moment
the president took office
it was incredibly challenging around
here don't tell Dr Patrick how many
pieces of gum I've swallowed
is a period of remarkable division in
the country Delta was raging things were
really falling apart
time to end the Forever War Biden's
cabinet not stupid people and they got
this really wrong president ghani said
to me on the phone I will stay and fight
to the Dead
he fled the country the next day
the United States has never seen an
adversary like this before we are in a
global struggle and autocracy is on the
rise I knew a moment would come when you
would need old alliances
that moment came with Ukraine
we began to pick up a massive Russian
military buildup so we go to Moscow
quietly I found President Putin to be
Unapologetic at his appetite for risk
has grown I conveyed serious
consequences that would flow from
military aggression the Biden
Administration learn from the mistakes
made in Afghanistan they responded by
getting out ahead of events instead of
being behind them we're living at an
inflection point in history we're
engaged in a struggle between democracy
and autocracy they're betting the
democracy's days are numbered
foreign